this show has been more than a decade of
your life how are you preparing for it
all to end it kind of in some ways has
ended for us you know we've finished
when we finished filming we we say
goodbye to it so it's this is sort of
just seems like an added bonus that
we're getting to watch it and celebrate
it now I'm I'm I'm kind of I said to
Rose the other night I was like we've
been tethered by this show for a long
time we've loved it and now we get to
enjoy the final hurrah we get to enjoy
seeing you on Saturday Night Live this
week how are you preparing just time to
read there I'm like shucked on a suit
and came here it's brilliant I've it's
it's that's a dream come true but I
could hear the crowd of people cheering
the premiere of the show the final
season of my show while I was doing the
read-through with SNL like that was a
bizarre moment for me who do you think
deserves okay then we have your question
from Amelia Clark what's the best meal
you had on the set of Game of Thrones I
don't know whatever Amelia
[Music]